vous l'aimez y SaintLaurent
ah c'est compliqué
oui forcément mais je l'aime avec des
critique voilà je mais oui bien sûr je
l'aime moi je l'aime
[Musique]
aussi est-ce que Luc Besson est un
producteur heureux ce soir oui je suis
toujours heureux moi d'être à can ouais
toujoursou toujours et en plus avec ce
film de Bertrand Bonello consacré à
Saint-Laurent ouais c'est un très beau
film c'est une espèce de valcelante
vénimeuse c'est très beau et et voilà
j'ai aussi trouvé énormément de
confiance en
Bertrand donc je dirais que oui le ce
dont je suis fier c'est c'est c'est
d'être arrivé au bout de cette
expérience ce qui était pas forcément
évident au départ vu vu dans l'état de
de peur dans lequel
j'étais je pense aussi que de faire
western pour moi c'est un peu un rêve
d'enfant ou parce que c'était les les
premiers films que j'aiaimé quand
j'étais gamin
et c'est rentré dans un univers qui pour
moi magnifique c'était un plaisir mais
un Danois qui fait un western c'est pas
un peu étrange c'est pas étrange c'est
de la folie mais non oui c'est étrange
c'est crazy quoi Salma ayek qui était
qui était là il y a quelques instants
évidemment avec ce petit mot qui
concerne toutes ces lycéennes qui sont
retenus prisonnières encore aujourd'hui
par beaucoup Haram Julie Gillet et la
réalisatrice Lisa sont également marqué
le coup tout à l'heure sur les
[Musique]
marches s'il vous plaît
salut les mecs pardon salut les mecs et
et comment on fait pour jouer un rôle
comme celui de DSK bah en se foutant à
poil ma couille ah oui non mais bah quoi
tu crois peut-être que l'intrigue se
passe au FMI tu crois que c'est un film
de comptable non bien sûr non et
pourquoi ne pas sortir welcome to New
York au cinéma bah parce que sie tu as
pas le droit de te palucher non Gérard
impossible de se balader dans une salle
avec un gant de toilette rempli de purée
ce serait pas correct arrêtez s'il vous
plaît ben quoi fais pas ta morer tu es
bien content d'en parler de mon film
hein ça t'excite tu le sais que c'est
pas une comédie romantique c'est un film
porno c'est
tout c'est la première fois que je joue
un premier rôle j'avoue que ça fait
bizarre de se voir en vrai j'ai lâché ma
petite
larme ah ben l'intelligence gêne
toujours mais si cette intelligence a un
petit vis caché c'est c'est démontable
dans Shakespeare vous avez les mêmes
situations dans toutes les grandes
tragédies ou même vous avez les mêmes
situations quand Orgon surprend tartuf
en train de de faire une déclaration
d'amour à Elmir l'autre il se met à ses
genoux et puis Orgon ne le croit pas il
dit mais c'est pas possible ce que je
viens d'entendre au ciel
estil tu vois je m'en souviens plus
donnez-moi à boire donnez-moi à boire de
l'eau je nai que de l'eau je suis désolé
non non je vois
plus lequel d'entre vous est le plus
délicat Antonio peut-être prenez vos
micro pour
parleraccep préu quelque chose pour
demain
mettre une drôle de conversation mais
non on verra ce que je mettrai sur les
marches on sait pas jouer on a des
flingues euh ben non je crois que j'ai
rien oublié ah oui simplement pour qu'il
y ait pas de jalousie j'aimerais bien
qu'on qu'on soit toute payé
pareil que vous
voilà je suis considéré comme un des
meilleurs au bras de fer par ici et s'il
y en a un de vous ce que ça intéresse je
suis prêt à le prendre tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
personne je dis rien
[Applaudissements]
dis
juste un mot en solo enfin je veux dire
harison le tournage du nouveau Star Wars
a débuté vous ne quitterez pas ce
plateau sans m'avoir dit quelque chose à
propos de Star
Wars ok
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
voir tu bouges et tu vois au loin devant
toi comme une
fournée tu
bois tu bouges et tu souris au moin
devant toi comme un
S pour
moi tu danses et tu penses et tu penses
à quoi comme à
cela auevir